des factures précise à la seconde près
dans le sillage de sfr orange
l'opérateur de téléphonie mobile va
passer d'ici le 15 septembre la
tarification à la seconde
la pression des consommateurs il ya été
pour beaucoup séverine lebrun cyril pack
dépose des photos jamais pour deux
minutes et dans dans le khat à 5 minutes
chez l agence durée de l'appel cette
seconde 12 facturations une minute en
moyenne sur 1 forte de six heures en
consommateur perd deux heures à cause de
ces appels courts difficile à avaler
à partir du moment où effectivement
qu'on soit une orange on paie une orange
donc vous consommez pas
dans la rue non enfin il demande arrive
à partir du 15 septembre
orange ne facturera que la seconde
consommer une bonne nouvelle pour les
clients mais il reste quand même sur
leurs gardes
je suis très méfiant donc je me dis que
ça doit être encore un angle coup le
commercial et qui doivent essayer de qui
vont rattraper ça ailleurs
effectivement désormais quand madame
oronges appellera monsieur sfr ou
monsieur huyghe elle paiera un
supplément 12 centimes d'euro la minute
parce qu'elle n'accepte pas parce que
l'une des qualités de service c'est ce
qu'on appelle l'inter opérabilité faire
je peux appeler de coût aussi facilement
mon propre réseau jeumont l'opérateur
que les autres réseaux et les opérateurs
français ont toujours fait ça il n'y a
aucune raison qu'ils reviennent en
arrière
orange assure que grâce à ce nouveau
décompte près de 80% de ses clients se
retrouveront gagnant l'opérateur aussi
car ils espèrent bien pousser à la
consommation
cette tarification un coup bien sûr mais
nous pensons qu'avec ce bénéfice que
nous apportons aux clients ils vont
consommer plus
nous pensons donc que ceci va accroître
leur usage
nous pensons par ailleurs que ceci va
augmenter notre part de marché
la tarification à la seconde c'est le
nouveau dada des opérateurs essaient
faire l'a décidé dès le mois dernier et
buc télécoms devraient suivre d'ici la
fin de l'année